Speaker 1: We have learned about the forthcoming
testimony of the former deputy national security
adviser to Donald Trump in front of the January
six Trump Riot Committee. This is a really,
really big deal. Now, I know many of you are
wondering the same thing. I'm wondering, is this
witness, the one that Donald Trump tried to call
in order to tamper with influence his forthcoming
testimony? We don't know the answer to that, but
we'll get back to that in a moment. First on CNN,
former Trump National Security Council official
will testify at Thursday's January six hearing.
This is not like some intern or coffee
boy. This is the deputy national security
adviser. And in fact, it's widely known
that the deputy national security adviser
is often the person really running the National
Security Council. Who's who who becomes sort of
the intermediary between the Security Council,
the national security adviser and everybody else.
Matthew Pottinger is his name. He served on
Trump's NSC before resigning in the aftermath
of January 6th. There is a primetime hearing on
Thursday night. My intent, like Joe Biden says,
my intent is to cover it, baby permitting. He will
testify publicly at Thursday's primetime hearing.
Pottinger is slated to appear alongside former
Trump White House aide Sarah MATTHEWS, who is
believed to have quite extreme or nuanced nuance
or both really insights into the Trump White
House. CNN previously reported that MATTHEWS,
who was deputy press secretary until resigning
shortly after January six, was expected to testify
publicly. When she resigned, Matthew said she was
honored to serve in Trump's administration,
but was deeply disturbed by what she saw.
Pottinger, Trump's deputy national security
adviser, stepped down in response to Trump's
reaction to his supporters breaching the U.S.
Capitol. He told people there was very little
for him to consider. A spokesperson for
the committee has declined to comment.
We are going to see some very, very real stuff
on what is right now the final scheduled hearing
from the January six Trump Riot Committee.
The headline here dramatically understates
who Matthew Pottinger was. It simply says
National Security Council official. As I said,
we're talking here about the principal deputy
national security adviser. Front row. To
everything that was going on in that extremely
high level organization, group committee,
whatever you want to call it. Now, there are a
few things that are going to happen. First of all,
is the question, did Donald Trump call you
to try to talk to you about this testimony?
And we don't know the answer to that. We know
her, Liz Cheney, that Donald Trump tried to call
some forthcoming witness. It may be Matthew
Pottinger, it may not. Hopefully, members of
Congress on the committee asked that question on
Thursday, and we will get an answer. Number two,
Trump will probably attempt the typical smear
campaign that he does when people testify
and when people become disgruntled
or whatever term you want to use,
he will say, This was not a particularly good
employee. He wasn't particularly bright and on and
on and on. And of course, there are two different
issues with that. Number one, Trump says it about
everyone who has something negative to say about
him. That's number one. And of course, number two,
Trump ran on I know how to hire people. And the
best people I can tell who's good and who's not
good. I can tell who's smart. Not smart, good at a
job. And individual after individual who is left.
We're talking about Rex Tillerson. We're
talking about John Bolton. It's a very
long list. Cassidy Hutchinson. More recently
in terms of the witnesses in this committee.
Trump attacks them and says they weren't smart and
all these different things. Well, you hired him.
You hired him and you said you're hiring
was really the best thing that you did. Now,
what happens after the committee is done? We
don't know the answer to that. There is the
the question continues to be, will Merrick Garland
and the Department of Justice charge anyone based
on what was learned in this committee? We don't
know the answer to that. I think that there are
two different ways to look at this. One, if you
came to me and you said, sir. Obama Right. Do you
have any reason to believe Merrick Garland plans
to charge people based on this committee? I would
say no. I have no reason to believe that. The only
thing we've heard is the DOJ is paying attention
to the committee hearings. Okay. But we have seen
no evidence that Garland is willing to do what
would be admittedly very difficult in charging
some of these former officials. On the other hand,
it is true that it takes a while to put cases
together, and it's completely plausible, realistic
that if indeed the DOJ learned about possible
crimes from watching the committee hearings
and they started investigations only when
the committee committee hearings took place,
it's completely plausible that it would take a
couple to a few months to put together a case and
investigate whether there are charges there are
confident they could get a guilty verdict on. So.
The timing is not really the issue for me. It's
reasonable that they hear about something in June
and they might charge in October or November
or December that the timeline isn't really
the concern. The concern is it seems
as though there's kind of a meekness
with regard to even really seriously
considering charging these people
up to and including Donald Trump.
And that's what makes me wonder,
is it just they're putting cases together or
is it there's no real interest and willingness
to actually do what would be very difficult but
would be the right thing to do if that's where
the facts point. Let me know what you think
is taking place. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. I also want to remind you next
Tuesday, one week from today is the next David
Pakman show viewer town hall. These are you know,
we do the calls on the Friday show, but we don't
have that much time for it, usually about 20,
25 minutes. Next Tuesday, 6 p.m. Eastern time,
3 p.m. Pacific US. Of course, for our friends
in Europe, it'll be, you know, like midnight.
We are going to be opening up the phone lines
and we will be taking an hour to an hour and a
half of calls. Everybody is welcome to call in if
you want to watch. Here's the sort of key thing.
It will only air on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. It won't be on the main YouTube channel,
the one with the roughly 1.5 million subscribers.
It won't be on Twitch, it won't be on Facebook.
We will only be streaming the town hall on the
Pacman Live YouTube channel. Everybody can watch,
everybody can participate. And yes, if you
are a website member, you will get priority
access to participate in the town hall. All
right. More about that as we get closer.
The David Pakman Show is made possible
by viewers and listeners through the
membership program you can sign up at. Join Pack
Mint.com. We do an extra show every day for our
members. We also offer a commercial free audio
feed and a commercial free video feed of the
show every single day. And it's
also available roughly five to.
Speaker 2: Watch a lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: That's weird. Where did that come from?
Well, listen, you will not be sued for taking
advantage of membership and. And you can use the
coupon code. Big voting 22 at. Join Pacman
dot com. Wow mike pillow out of nowhere